Hello Maiduan
I'm gonna for your mama sister Marie
I'm waka boy do UK Majidiso Obiya and Hoya
wait a just a quick one for asensubuachi
metea in the interview be m senra
an ogrante interview no
now asensubuachi say lawyer Ralph in Japan
is a mismatch at the mano
because Loya Ralph a visionless
enough is or you unprepared for about to wanna
a contest in a war more corner
now may present me bizarre sense of what you say
I'm not president of Kufwadu Ekofa Dr Bawalmir
a Free Bank of Ghana
Edina Baza Omra Mayer ne Rani mate Dr Bawalmir
now I have politics that Development Bank
now so Ghana for m P P for a t a C m a president
a kufwado candidate a kufwado at the time
m a Bauwomiya
m a BA Yeh running mates
m a party m a a membership card a nue Tre
N o d d h r d N m o r n a n a Doctor Baroomiya Diababa
your politician
a n a o Jana
as presidential hopeful
why is student leader pain test
confounder pain find the question here
what are now the president of Kufwadwa
chief from 2:08 as a personal assistant 2012 2016
what committee thinks I can see
it wouldn't impart in Pennsylvania
Norma Bibbria
it is neither here nor there
because lawyer RAF in Japan
in fact NRKC he's the most powerful
and the most influential politician in Ghana
can I do a Japon can I do a japon? Can I do a japon?
Experience, experience after all
laugh eh eh, parliamentary eh,
Jumano eh, you Nippon who? Eh, Juman eh d n eh,
you Nippon who? Eh, Juman eh Chen is a obedient lawyer. Ne
sometimes
you put prison,
save people from going to prison,
from getting into trouble.
And our face was, what's it then?
Er experience for Parliament.
Parliament yakoshamra development
and your parliamentary development, a local authority.
It doesn't hold any water.
Who begged you when you saw next week Saturday
and check now honourable candies do not own him
and the man will tune in.
We are around for four, says a
woman.
Or your visionless or your mismatch
developer? Who
is the developer?
Next
week Saturday.